what i have to say about all of that is
what a waste of time because they don't
touch
any of it i know bro
none of these characters change they're
the same [ __ ] people at the end of
the movie even after the end credits
roll what do they do karaoke again we'll
have to change the bit pro
i'm so glad you said that
because
that was one of my initial like biggest
gripes that already put me in a bad mood
for the film right
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast i am your host
david soh and i have my co-host for the
day
ed park what's up and you know what no
[ __ ] fluff we're just gonna go right
the [ __ ] into it man so how was your
weekend
[Laughter]
well you you were in sacramento i was uh
i was in sacramento when you know it's
interesting every time i go back to
sacramento because
you know like growing up
when you kind of grow up in an area that
doesn't have a lot of money and you're
right there yeah you don't notice these
things because everybody's poor right
nobody has money right and i've been so
accustomed and i've gotten used to what
sacramento is specifically part that i
grew up because there's a lot of parts
in sacramento that's that's [ __ ] nice
yeah right um
not so much my area yeah so i was there
i just i just looked around i was like
look at these [ __ ] hoodlums dude
it's like those places i used to kick it
at yeah you know
and so that's true i would never go back
to some of the places you used to hang
out in tacoma oh 100 yeah and so when uh
i went to this wedding shout out to my
buddy william and sung they got married
beautiful [ __ ] marriage but um just
to say how ghetto it is one of the
bridesmaids got their catalytic
converter stolen the night of the
wedding what
oh god did you have a prius i don't
[ __ ] know oh my god i felt so i was
like damn bro [ __ ] sacramento dude
dude there's a huge epidemic of people
stealing like catalytic converters these
days there's some type of metal that
people want right like precious metals
in there yeah or something like that
because i i got my catalytic converter
stolen out of my honda element
oh yeah that was one of the biggest
reasons why i had to let it go because
apparently it's so easy to jack oh yeah
it's so high off the ground yeah so
people just go in and swipe it super
easy but um yeah i was in sacramento for
a little bit went to the river did all
the other [ __ ] and of course this
weekend or actually yesterday i went to
watch the movie that everybody told me
to go watch and we're talking about
shanghai yeah the the legend of the ten
[ __ ] [ __ ] rings i'm kidding you know
the 10 bracelets didn't have the right
ring to it
the 10 to 10 bracelets
yeah
but i i saw it opening day
uh oh you saw it like thursday afternoon
thursday 9pm
and uh
i walked out of it when we got home it
was like it was pretty [ __ ] late
because it was it was longer than i
expected i think it was like
something around 1am but did you go to a
10 30 viewing i think it was like a 9 20
viewing or 9 40 viewing or some [ __ ]
yeah i did around the same time yeah i
got out like one so
uh
i i get home i lay in bed and i'm just
like what the [ __ ] did i think about
that movie i couldn't sleep because i
had diet coke at the theater oh yeah i
haven't had it in such a long i also
quit uh drinking coffee in the morning
so now i'm hypersensitive to caffeine
that's me i couldn't sleep so i just was
thinking about the movie and i just
started writing my notes
next thing i know there's 12 paragraphs
of notes of my thoughts
so a few days later i go back to watch
it again because i don't want to be like
you know maybe i had these expectations
and what i thought it was gonna be
and so if i see it a second time there's
no expectations i know what it is then
i'm just gonna like it for what it is
but my thoughts just stay the same like
i
now i don't want people to think about
here's the thing
anytime somebody
so far the rhetoric has been when
there's an asian film out there
i feel pressured to say that i liked it
you're supposed to like it you're
supposed to post about it you're
supposed to tell everyone it's an a-plus
[Laughter]
like with uh crazy rich asians right
yeah that whole vibe they they were
telling me that people were looking at
me wide-eyed like hey man well that was
such a good film i did not think it was
[ __ ] good right but i kept my
opinions to myself now having said that
crazy rich asians was what two three
years ago yeah we have now progressed
since that i think we we are having a
lot more asian american films and i
think that it's okay for me to say my
opinions uh once the film comes out and
i don't i don't have to [ __ ] hold
back anymore yeah right and i have a
certain level of expectations just for
film in general and i think that asian
americans and asian films uh or or
people who are highlighted or asian
americans who are highlighted in these
american films can do really [ __ ]
well yes so having said that what the
[ __ ] man
like
here's the thing
so read so many reviews right a lot of
my peers were like this is one of this
is probably top five best mcu movies
ever
that was one of the things that people
were saying that it was either top five
or top three best mcu movies ever yeah
so before we go ahead and kind of break
it down i do want to start this off with
some positivity about what i liked about
it i was gonna say we should sandwich it
like say nice things and then we'll get
to the meat and we'll bread it up with
some nice things
um
first off
some of the best fight choreography and
marvel anything yeah amazing winter
soldier was up there with
some of the best fight choreography this
one one update for sure the bus the the
bus fight scene in the beginning of the
film how [ __ ] good was that dude it
was dope no the and the best fight scene
was him versus that ninja dude yeah yeah
and that guy's actually a buddy of mine
really he's an interview
shout out to andy dude that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] dope
yeah he's he's like andy too uh him and
his brother they just trained like in
their house and their garage and in the
park and they've been wanting to do
action films they've been uh influenced
by people like jackie chan donnie yen
all these like og martial arts films but
a lot of people forget about right
because we're so used to in film
watching why i call it the jason statham
effect where it's the quick pans the the
fast whips right right but of course
when you watch stuff like um like
drunken master and everything else wide
shots all long takes right you had to be
someone who was really good at wushu who
was really good at martial arts in order
for you to execute this stuff right so
uh they kind of these these young men
they've been
uh training and doing their own fight
choreography on youtube and instagram
for [ __ ] years and now they've been
booking roles because there's not a lot
of people who can do what what they do
and it's so [ __ ] good and it was
apparent in the film so shout outs to
andy that was [ __ ] sick and then um
what else nice things you got to say
about it
i want to give shout outs to
two actors that i thought were really
really good in that film tony lung yes
tony [ __ ] long dude in the eyes
everything is in the eyes and this is
there was one part of the movie that i
that
that really got me was it was when uh
shang chi looked at his father and he
tells him hey
what do you what makes you think that
you know your mother want my mother
wants to see you anyways and no words
you look in his face that anger and
disappointment in his son and that's all
that needed to be said yeah this by the
way english is not this man's first
language and he was the best actor in
that film i read up on a scene
apparently when he says don't talk to me
like that young man but he's talking to
the old ass dude yeah yeah right and he
says i've lived a thousand more
lifetimes than you oh so cool but
apparently the actual translation is
i've tasted more salt than you've eaten
rice your whole life that's [ __ ]
tight why did they just say that yeah
right why didn't it so i i would say
like that would be our first little
mishap you know that that kind of ruined
it for us i guess like when you have a
mistranslation like sometimes that might
be the problem subtitles but that's like
a little nitpicky thing it would have
been dope if they just said you know
i've eaten more salt than you've eaten
rice that's amazing because like you
know the chinese language is very
beautiful there's a lot of idioms in
there i don't know why they translated
that i don't think it needed to be
translated that way i think people would
have understood it through the yeah
also two female shout out uh
i think fala chen she was the one that
played uh shanghai's mom okay yeah she
was [ __ ] awesome yeah by the way i
mean she did a a lot of her lines were
in like mandarin
but either way she was also really
really good yeah i thought her acting
was [ __ ] amazing too like the like
especially the way she kind of portrayed
her relationship with the young chiang
chi and the daughter and how much she
cared and in the few moments that she
had in the film i thought was [ __ ]
really good so those two were my
favorite obviously shout outs to
benedict wong he's actually one of my
favorite um
uh asian actors out there until this day
yeah so seeing
benedict wanda was always a [ __ ]
treat other than that what the [ __ ]
it was a sitcom
right
okay i mean let's start from the
beginning of the film right
the first 15 minutes of the film was the
best
when i first when i was watching the the
fight choreography between uh tony lung
and fala yeah
[ __ ] amazing
what it reminded me of was
this is what mulan wanted to be right
right that fight scene that whole choreo
everything that was happening in there
especially when they were coming in he
was destroying all the arrows he was it
kind of went through him just
obviously in the thousand years he's
been alive just [ __ ] everybody up
yeah i was like this is kind of what
mulan wanted to be yeah or what i was
expecting from mulan when it came to the
fight scenes and and that that choreo
and dance that he was doing with his
wife was [ __ ] dope right like it was
amazing that they can use fight scenes
um
instead of you know them going out for
ice cream yeah yeah yeah yeah
like for flirtation and like there's
some chemistry here going on you know
which is great um
it goes on to the story of when
it kind of moves on like he just wakes
up from a dream and he's in a garage
right
um
he's living in squalor you know he takes
they takes the bus to work
uh
he
goes to uh see
aquafina at her house katie that's her
name well they went to the um
they went to go do their job their their
what it what it was their their valet
here's here's already the first mishap
in this right this is what was so
[ __ ] dumb i already knew off of this
part this is where i immediately rolled
my eyes so
simu oh i'm sorry simula was the main
actor
yeah
shang chi or sean as he's called at this
point in the film
he's laying in bed he's doing all the
push-up stuff right he looks like
whatever i know it was that the whole uh
bruce
bruce wayne type of thing wakes up
starts doing the push-ups next to the
bed type of scene right yeah
even though that's a dc film and they go
over to this scene where you see this
expensive car roll out and you see this
asian guy come out of it right which by
the way they were trying to make it seem
like it was shangqi right you already
showed us
what he looks like yeah and you already
showed that he's poor yeah
so why the [ __ ] would we think that that
was him yeah it was supposed to be a
joke yeah but how
i stopped and i was like
that was supposed to be a joke yeah that
like wrong punch line for a different
joke
you already [ __ ] up you gave the
[ __ ] punch line already yeah he's
already poor in the beginning part and
then you showed this guy come out and
what they were trying to do was like oh
we want to trick the audience for to
make them believe that that's shanghi
and then it cuts to him being a valet
person but we already saw what he looked
like and you showed a different asian
guy why the [ __ ] would we think that's
him maybe the joke is that he's this
yuppy asian dude who spent all his money
on a bmw so he could live in a poor ass
[ __ ] cockroach infested garage and
when i saw that and then they revealed
the agent it was a different asian guy
and then it goes it dry cuts to him
going picking up the car yeah it's like
bro we already know the joke yeah we
already saw the other asian guy but it's
not him it fell short already yeah
i mean aside from
like um
it was already in the trailer too yes
like thanks for giving that away exactly
it didn't make any sense i'm like what
the [ __ ] is this you know what it was
that scene was paid for by bmw
it's product placement yeah for sure i
mean the m8 is a [ __ ] sick ass car
but that's another conversation yeah
you know um the
the important parts come like um
he
he goes to katie's house and his mom
answers the door takes off his shoes
cute scene
and um
the main argument that the mother has
with katie is when are you gonna go get
a real job right and she kind of has
that attitude like maybe i like my job
maybe i like you know going out with my
friends maybe i like what i'm doing or
whatever yeah and she walks out and then
the grandma says to sean
uh when are you two getting married and
he says we're just friends
right
and
okay um platonic friendship all right
here we go
and they
go to a bar
and the there was an indian canal yeah
yeah
shout outs to [ __ ] canal too by the
way man it was dope seeing him in the
film so they're in a bar and canal's
dating a a
a chinese girl
and they're a couple and they're meeting
with them too and they're talking about
high school how they were rowdy
and then they go what happened to you
you know
how come you're not used to be so wild
why aren't you like and she says because
i grew up you know i got a job i
found there are more important things in
life
maybe you guys need to apply some of
that in your life right pretty typical
asian american like story you want to
tell when the the the social pressures
of like you know assimilating in america
um
what i have to say about all of that is
what a waste of time because they don't
touch any of it i know bro
none of these characters change they're
the same [ __ ] people at the end of
the movie even after the end credits
roll what do they do karaoke again we'll
have to change a bit bro
i'm so glad you said that
because
that was one of my initial like biggest
gripes that already put me in a bad mood
for the film right if you are going to
use these things as like a moral
standpoint or maybe even an insight into
culture right there has to be a growth
in the character yeah one of the biggest
faults that they had in um shanghai is
that i didn't give a [ __ ] about him dude
yeah you know who i gave a [ __ ] about
the mandarin tony yeah yeah
i gave so much [ __ ] about him because
he actually had a heart right yeah
champion
he abandoned his [ __ ] sister yeah
right
disappeared for danier 16 [ __ ] years
right
and then what comes to kill his [ __ ]
dad because his heart is running because
his mom his wife [ __ ] got murdered
yeah he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i was like
yeah there was literally like no
character change or like what he
believed like i didn't even understand
his relationship with his father to be
honest like my brain farts this podcast
is brought to you by skillshare listen
to me i'm a cut to the chase i know
you're like me you have hobbies you have
goals and a bunch of things you want to
learn and try but you don't know where
to get the right information because
there's a lot of garbage out there
skillshare is an online learning
community that offers membership with
meaning with so much to explore real
projects to create in the support of
fellow creative skillshare empowers you
to accomplish real growth don't be the
seed that's in the dirt that turns out
to be a poop plant get some real growth
son the course i'm checking out right
now is youtube success script shoot and
edit by marcus brownlee one of my
favorite online creators and i've been
doing this a very long time but you guys
already know your boy is about learning
and upping his skills mkbhd thanks for
the tips so remember explore your
creativity at skillshare.com brain and
get a free trial of premium membership
that's skillshare.com
brain
are you pissed off because you know you
know right before their big fight scene
he says i'm not afraid of you anymore
and i'm like were you afraid
exactly dawg
that
when that line literally made no sense
yeah what did you do to earn
having that moment to say i'm not afraid
of you anymore
we didn't even know you were yeah
it didn't show in any of the flashbacks
it seems like you guys had a really
great relationship yeah and in fact he
taught you everything and how to fight
and in fact what it actually shows that
your relationship was pretty good
because
you looked you i kind of actually
idolized your father because there was
that saying the whole blood for blood
thing and you agreed you wanted revenge
for your mother that's what it seemed
like anyways yeah and then when he went
off to the mission he just disappeared
yeah don't know if he got revenge or
killed anybody so um
we'll we'll get to the story because
after that scene they're riding the bus
and they get attacked dope [ __ ] scene
it was dope how they turned into like
kind of a mini hallway scene when
they're traveling through the bus shout
outs old boy yeah it was a great great
fight scene
um after that
so
katie learns that shawn knows kung fu
yes
and what you're a badass you're da da da
da and this and that and then he kind of
says yeah they're they're the members of
the ten rings organization they're after
me blah blah blah so i have to go to
where they are
why did you run away in the first place
again yeah
wouldn't you go disappear again yeah why
were you in hiding from your father and
they found you what's motivating you to
go back
nothing you just decide to
instead of it would seem like in the
character we're seeing it would be
motivated to hide even further
nope
as much as we wanted this to be an
asian-american film it's they fly to
[ __ ] china
on a base where there's all these white
henchmen
also dude that was the weird thing right
it's like this underground
chinese badass thing eighty percent of
russian yeah
what what is happening here what is
going on and also too
you know i think his motivation he said
was oh i gotta they're gonna go after my
sister next you already abandoned her
for 16 [ __ ] years you've had no
contact
what are you talking about she could be
dead for all the [ __ ] you know you left
her when she was 10 years old
and why is she even more in danger now
than she was 10 years ago and you not
knowing what the [ __ ] happened to her
what motivation do you have in there
besides oh you two share a pendant from
your mom that's it yeah but why do we
care and we don't even at this point
care about depending on his mom yeah you
know because
we just they just tell her us she dies
and then they they do the flashback in
the middle of the movie
and then by that point it's like then we
don't care about those pendants still
you know it should have mattered for us
to care like if if shawn doesn't care
then we don't care
right
and in the same way with katie's
character she's supposed to be
our
um fish not for shadow water but like
the everyday person like you and i we
follow the story through her eyes of how
unbelievable this is
look no
no qualms about aquafina and her acting
to be honest but i have a problem with
her character
yeah yeah
um
her acting wasn't that great in this
film either
like i said it's a sitcom yeah marvel
sitcoms well this is i mean we could
talk about this part too right
was it just me or did it feel like
all the budget was put into the cgi and
all the fighting and when it came to the
important parts of the film too which is
the dialogue which progresses the story
they could give two [ __ ] less about how
it was lit how it was shot and the
direction and the acting yeah that's
what i felt right i i don't know how
many times there was a joke that
completely missed and the theater was
quiet
[Laughter]
every time they had a joke
i kept on hearing this
i'm not korean i'm chinese yeah like
[Laughter]
like get your stereotypes right too
right the whole you know the whole
karaoke thing is a is a korean filipino
thing yeah most you know asian people
know but also too it's just you know
they kind of
did the joke where um there was the
asian girl who was studying on her
laptop at the uh bus she goes i bet you
my mom wanted me to be like her cool and
then they sliced the laptop and she goes
no
[Applause]
i'm like [ __ ] hell dude yeah like
there's murderers on the bus right now
yeah
exactly and it's just i had the vagina
joke on the bus too my mom would be so
proud if she came out of my mom's vagina
yeah
that's super
you know like those were moments in the
theater where there wasn't a lot of
people in the theater because i went
late but nobody was laughing yeah it's
just like
who wrote these [ __ ] jokes why are
these jokes so bad i i kind of i went
into the chinese theater so there was a
lot of marvel fans obviously
um
and from my end of my experience was
sometimes i was wondering why people
were laughing
and uh or why are they applauding on
some parts or whatever um i mean i
followed the mcu deep
we're both marvel fans we grew up with
this and mind you too
i'm doing everything in my ball sack to
love this film by the way like i don't
want to dislike these parts yeah we're
not here just trying to be contrarian
because all of our friends are hyping
the movie we're trying to give our best
objective opinions that's kind of an
oxymoron but you know yeah that's the
nature of movie reviews and
the thing too it's like the dialogue was
so bad like it made me feel like they
didn't care about the dialogue at all
and i understand that there are certain
films too where you mainly focus on the
action but because this is within the
marvel universe you need the dialogue to
explain the story about what's going on
if there's going to be this much
exposition yes you better write this
[ __ ] well right like hateful eight the
most expositionist
exposition movie ever but why is it so
awesome because quentin tarantino writes
dope dialogue yeah you know and they
just that's what this is what i was so
confused about right is
are is there acting bad or was the
writing that bad that they couldn't act
well
i i believe it's the latter okay see
that's what i'm saying it's like
how i felt so weird watching this it
felt like a youtube sketch yeah
especially that the the bar scene where
they're just talking having that casual
conversation yeah it's like am i
watching something on youtube right now
exactly it looked like a youtube channel
it seemed like a very improvised [ __ ]
movie yeah like dialogue they kind of
just threw away you guys be yourselves
and and just say whatever you would say
it was just and also too the acting was
extremely over the top
like that's why i say sitcom yeah
i i thought there was going to be a
laugh track every time they made a joke
like what the [ __ ] is are we on the set
of everybody loves raymond yeah or is
this a [ __ ] marvel film or the fact
that okay so my biggest problem i was
gonna get to about katie
was you know me saying that she is our
eyeballs you know because she's the
normal person right
um
except when she starts taking in the
story and seeing the surreal like crazy
magic kung fu and all this [ __ ] she's
supposed to come to terms with it and we
we see the unbelievable happen through
her so we suspend our disbelief
but too many jokes she kept mocking
everything that kept happening
right so uh they go to macau they have
the dope ass [ __ ] fight uh the
[ __ ] scaffolding fight too
like
callbacks to a rush hour two and many
other
uh jackie chan
movies um they get captured by their
father
father's very affectionate with shang
chi so why are you mad at him
no but uh
they they have dinner
and he does more exposition about the
mandarin and who the true mandarin is
um
and he actually says it's time for you
to
take up my place in the ten rings
organization and he's like i would never
do that
and then we're sitting here waiting why
yeah
you know you live in a [ __ ] basement
your dad's a [ __ ] billionaire you
know you don't want to live for a
thousand years bro like that life seems
dope
you know you know why this was so
confusing to me why i started rolling my
eyes was the scene in where uh
his mom fala
dies yeah the way that it was set up i
thought his dad killed his mom yeah
really okay well because because he
hated his dad right because he kept he
was i'll never take this over i was like
what's what's the reason why he hates
his dad so much right and i was like he
must have killed his mom or something
it was somebody else yeah and then
so that's where the exposition goes
wrong because you're going to flashback
that but then you're going to exposition
a key [ __ ] point
the exact point that you're talking
about missing
which is they go into halfway
on the airplane right he he gives the
flashback story scene his mom died so he
got trained like a [ __ ] like him
growing up right being trained to be an
assassin very harshly and his sister
isn't though sister's pushed in the
background and she has to learn on her
own
and
uh
[Music]
basically they get interrupted and then
because before he was going to say his
dad set him up it gave him a spirit go
finally kill the person responsible
of murdering his his mom and then
peanuts or whatever hahaha
yeah
and and then she goes did you go through
with it and he says no
you know all right so we go to china
meet his sister she's the head of this
underground fight club
um
nice pants
you know i like your pants thanks
[Laughter]
and then okay fight scene their father
finds them they get flown out to the
mountains
uh somewhere
and that's where the organization the
headquarters is set up she goes back
into her
you know sees her old house and
she doesn't seem to give a [ __ ] at all
yeah
she ran away but she gave herself up uh
i don't know like there was a weird
line between altruism where she saves
and like helps katie from falling
and then the other one where she [ __ ]
axe kicks a [ __ ] off a building
yeah and then she goes america made you
soft yeah and then gets caught anyway
all right
fine i mean what are you gonna do
um
everything up to that point led to the
fact that those two pendants were
dragging eyeballs you know so they can
see a water map
of how to get to tallow
magical land
um that where when wu met his wife
you know
and
they and get and end up being tossed in
a prison cell right
and this is what i mean
after all that happened
katie mocks
what happened
yeah she says you know i thought your
dad needed therapy because of his
delusions but i'm beginning to think
it's real
and his sister his sister
says crazier things have come true right
meaning [ __ ] like you know thor and
asgard the [ __ ] chitar invasion and
avengers and all these cadillac
crazy events where we have even
you know a bunch of alien invasions and
magic sorcerers and all that
and because there's that before
we're supposed to accept this crazy
story yeah and with katie's character it
wasn't her processing it's like oh
that's happening
yeah
yeah
so if you don't give a [ __ ]
we don't give a [ __ ] yeah you know we're
just being told yep here's a ride over
and over and over again wow this is
crazy but it's happening cool it's
happening
and
also too like her character too like
what the [ __ ] was the point of your
character
you know right like it was supposed to
help us yeah for the ride or process
if you're his right-hand person right
were you there did you give him clarity
did you help like morally guide his
choices no she was a down ass [ __ ]
though
that's about it that's really about it
because it was so [ __ ] platonic
you know what i'm saying
this is the weird thing too right it's
like
so you know he hears about this whole
fable
so you know the dragon eyes opens up
this this this passageway because it's
very hard to get into the land that she
lives it's like this mystical his mom
lives in right or lived in because she
passed away yeah this mystical land with
all of yeah
with all these [ __ ] creatures right
and
it
i guess like the thing that really
bothered me was just like
it was a lot easier to get in there than
i thought it was too yeah
dad why'd you have such a hard time you
had the ten rings you had the ten rings
and you had this [ __ ] animal yeah you
know it was just a little too easy to
get it so that's what i'm saying about
what's missing like where we have to
keep assuming everyone's motives yeah
right like
this podcast is brought to you by fiverr
my friends we've all got that oddly
specific thing we're good at but no
one's great at everything fiverr
connects you to
best in class freelancers with
experience in hundreds of digital
specialties and every skill imaginable
to help you with any project listen i've
been doing business i've been in
entertainment for a very long time if i
did everything by myself i would get
nothing done and on top of that too
they're just people that you need to
outsource for freelance work when it
comes to making a business or doing your
job and i've been using fiverr for
everything from um
logos to like music stuff to animation
you name it they have the freelance work
that's right there and they communicate
super fast there's 24 7 customer service
um
pricing is always like project based so
you don't have to pay hourly which has
been a big pain in the ass before and
you don't have to do any guessing games
because you'll know exactly what you're
paying for upfront no negotiating needed
find a freelancer with the specific
skills you need for your next project
check out
fiverr.com and receive 10 off your first
order by using my code geniusbrain find
all the digital services you need in one
place at f i v e r r dot com code
geniusbrain again that's
fiverr.com code geniusbrain we should
have seen him getting banished from
tallow the first time because he meets
his wife
they fall in love
and maybe he wanted to live in tallow
right but they see the ten rings they
know they they know his past
right and so they he's forbidden from
coming in the city right but she's in
love so she stays with him and she
leaves the mystical you know you know
universe
out of love and he
you know has become resentful
because he wants it because he is a
conqueror he wants to go in there you
know but he's banished for his love but
he chooses love but what happens if
wives get murdered that's so much better
like motivation i just thought up of
that [ __ ] we don't see any of that
actually you know
so that's that's just the biggest
problem of this movie it's like it's so
unmotivated it's a roller coaster on
rails you get in for the ride and you
leave because it goes back to what we're
saying too it's like why is he such a
[ __ ] dick to his dad yeah
because he gave him every rationale to
tell him like listen i'm doing this
because i hear the voice of your mom i
think she's still alive right which by
the way in this mcu universe like as
mentioned in the film
crazier things have happened yeah so it
is believable right and we're talking
about chinese mysticism here we're
talking about magic so when he said that
in the beginning i believe him too like
there was no reason for me not to
believe that that was a possibility yeah
right but then he's sitting here like no
mom is dead right it just kind of shuts
down the [ __ ] conversation
immediately and he's like treating his
dad like he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] the
[ __ ] part really doesn't make sense
because all the exposition that went
into the background of his character his
him and his father actually had a good
relationship he taught him how to fight
and he was teaching him how to fight in
order to get revenge for it i wanted to
speak english
did you see how kind he was to him in
that part where he was teaching him how
to speak english yeah he showed himself
being a loving father he wasn't
cold-hearted in the film he didn't
mistreat him at all in fact he was very
heavy-handed in his upbringing yeah even
when they went into the bar right that
scene where he went to go find the um
the [ __ ] the gang that killed his the
brown jacket gang yeah right
he fought them up he [ __ ] him up and
then his son was like shocked at first
but he's like no that's right this is
this is right yeah and he went through
the training
so
let's let's get to around that so uh
going back where we left off uh with the
plot of the film uh
they're in a prison they find trevor the
old mandarin
you know great call back
uh he was a funny guy i think they did
it justice the only funny person in the
film
but
but
when he was giving that exposition about
the mandarin right
i think we could have seen some more
antagonistic side antagonistic side of
wenmu
maybe he pulled him out in chains and
made him perform for him right some evil
[ __ ] some bad guy [ __ ] that's why
xiangxi would need to stop his father
because oh my god you're a piece of [ __ ]
um or perhaps um
we can see that
uh wenmu with the ten rings could
destroy iron man that he would have been
an actual legit threat than the more
than the fake one in iron man 3. yeah
you know we didn't get that we just
these these guys are really good at kung
fu
you know why that triggers me
because that was the only way i got by
through high school some rumor went
around don't [ __ ] with him he knows kung
fu and somehow that's like the biggest
threat in the world
yeah yeah
so it's as if the audience is supposed
to be like oh
if they know kung fu then they're the
best movie you know protagonists or
antics whatever don't they're not to be
[ __ ] with yeah kind of thing which is
it just doesn't [ __ ] fly anymore you
got to tell us why not just tell us
actually you got to show us why because
there's enough exposition in telling it
it was just also too it's like they did
so such a big job and a big effort in
humanizing wenmu right
but nobody showed sympathy for him did
you notice that
nobody showed sympathy for this guy who
gave up being a warlord right to live a
peaceful life and raise his family had
everything taken away from him and his
biggest motivation now is just to get
his wife back his children had no
sympathy for him yeah whatsoever which
is gets more confusing towards the end
and we'll we'll get to that part but it
it's
the lack of motivation for why anybody
feels anything towards anybody yeah you
know it's like that's why it's just a
roller coaster it's like a sign that
passes by really fast
they're angry at each other
she's sad
this is funny
fight five five five fight you know
like
we're grateful for the great cgi it had
better cgi than black panther yeah you
know
but
if i could have
a
oscar nominated best picture worthy film
with bad cgi
or a stinker with great cgi
i'd go with the oscar-nominated stink
bad cgi right
uh we didn't get that one
i'll tell you this though
here's the thing so they get into this
part of the film right if we if we go
into the last act right it's the
the village in which his mom grew up
right yeah you get to see familiar faces
that we've seen in a lot of films
michelle yo yeah [ __ ] amazing seeing
her amazing actress shout outs to
michelle yo and we also saw he was in uh
uh kung fu hustle um
i forgot his name i don't know i'm i
just read his name i can't remember
right now but he was one of the the
village guys right yeah
can we also talk about how bad the
costume was for shanxi
that's why people say like
what's this guy's superpower well he
doesn't have any but he has a dragon
shirt
there's a t-shirt made out of jackets
like plastic rubies on a [ __ ] shirt
right and then this is the part that had
me dying laughing when they did a white
of his full outfit it was like pacsun
jeans and vans
yeah
some dockers what the
[ __ ] was that dude
so this gift that they gave up was like
you only need to protect your upper body
yeah don't worry about the bottoms just
looking at him like i'm going to blast
your dick off
the costume was so bad also too
the
the weapon design
the
the it just their sticks looked like a
burnt cigarette like that that was
losing the light you know just ash
and this was their [ __ ] it's like
it's dragon scales it looked terrible
the weapons did not look [ __ ] good
that's so like uh
the ten rings gain a gang follows them
under the waterfall
to their magical narnia i mean tallow
yes
to narnia with all the narnia creatures
flying about seriously like how are you
gonna argue that and say it's not narnia
oh and shout out to this thing being
this is gonna be the biggest war ever
it's like 50 people dude in the front
yard
[Laughter]
like in somebody's
by the way the body of water that in
which this dragon lives in is like a
pond yeah it must be like [ __ ] free
willy down there he would get me out i
know
it's just super small pond yeah maybe
it's deep
just [ __ ] ridiculous dude i was like
this is the magical world is
so small yes allocate to this really
really small spot well that's what i
mean like
that whole world got
hit at us in the third act
imagine asgard just coming in the last
few minutes of the film imagine like
wakanda come in the last minutes of
black panther you know what i'm saying
like they had no world building of it
except those wooden um like sculptures
yeah like those were sick i wonder if
they were real or cg but
you know like if they were gonna do more
exposition you know this they say we
have cities this is just a village
shout out to by the way in aquafina uh
what's her name katie katie in the film
learning how to shoot a bow in three
hours right
and that's the problem because at the
end
she mocks it yeah i learned like bow and
arrow in like a day and i killed the
dragon and i killed the cthulhu like
shot in the throat and then yo shout out
to all the people that died though huh
yeah
dude this scene wasn't supposed to be
funny but literally i cried laughing it
was when he was like shoot it in the
throat and as he says it throughout the
whole film he was like you're not ready
yet
he gets picked up and murdered in two
seconds right what the [ __ ] these
unfulfilling deaths like that badass
ninja dude
they they fight the best fight scene
they have a history because this
[ __ ] used to child abuse him
and they don't have an another one last
fight no this [ __ ] gets his soul
taken away like
man
like come on were you building
intentionally to just be like like come
on like you got to build that until that
big last fight
because what was the fight with his
father worth what did it mean it's this
father-son fight
like nothing didn't mean anything except
to tell us he's not afraid of him
anymore but we didn't know
dude two of the worst jokes happened in
the last act
it was when she was holding the bundle
of arrows and then me as i was just
sitting there i was with a friend and i
was like hey
we looked at each other we're like hey
she better not do the thing where she's
like i can't fit in the door because the
the sticks are too long and they [ __ ]
did it oh well whoa okay i should turn
the [ __ ] arrow sideways i'm like
who wrote the [ __ ] jokes man
and then tv sitcom writers dude it was
literally a tv sitcom and then when the
the the demons started coming down
right and then there was the big russian
guy right he's like we're not scared of
anybody papa okay maybe we need your
help
we should work together oh my god dude
why does he even have a sword for her
arm yeah how come he couldn't just have
a regular arm
just probably cost ten thousand dollars
per shot
exactly his sword arm did nothing for
the film yeah it literally did nothing
i mean
the
one of the other important scenes is
the night before the battle
uh shanxi is by himself by the lake
and
crying to himself and katie catches up
with him
and he starts going into exposition
finishing the story he didn't get to
finish on the airplane
and he tells her that he did go through
with the the assassination
right
and she goes wow your dad trained you to
be an assassin as a child and made you
do all these things that's messed up
he's like
yeah and then he wipes a tear from his
eye i'm like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
show us
please show us you killing this guy yeah
show us you as a badass teenage assassin
you know who
is [ __ ] angry but is scared
right finally has a chance to to get
revenge because of what the lies his
father has been telling him right
like his dad putting in his brain in
this mindset into murdering and getting
revenge yeah for him right
but then
uh let's
say we see him actually go through with
killing this guy getting his revenge but
him being horrified him being sick him
being traumatized over this dead body
because at this point he's only supposed
to be like 14 or 16 or some [ __ ] right
like what a real child soldier goes
through and why that's messed up show us
why it was so messed up
you know instead he's just this
you know what you did i don't like you
that scene i started laughing and once
again this is where i was conflicted is
it that c moves acting is really subpar
or was it the writing because he did he
was doing things in that scene that i
couldn't stop giggling at like i'm sad
and he turns away and he goes
[Laughter]
sitcom [ __ ] sitcom stuff it's like is
this his fault or is it the director's
fault at this point is it the writings
fall maybe it's it's it's one it was so
maybe [ __ ] corny yeah
and there's no
and what's that extra cheese and just to
go back to it right he's like he goes
i'm going to have to kill my father i'm
like why
why yeah you didn't even try to talk to
him [ __ ] if we had seen
him his trauma then we would also
understand his resentment for his father
there's a part in the film too where
he's a kid right he's constantly
punching that thing i think it was his
dad that told him hey you need to stop
and rest
[Laughter]
so
why is his dad such an [ __ ] there's
clearly something that happened in
between yeah right but there was a lot
of loving moments for wenmu throughout
that whole film yeah so why are you
going to kill him you didn't even try to
talk to him you just called him an idiot
and that he's dumb and of course his dad
flips out on him he's like dude take
them [ __ ] away right
he didn't even say hey dad
why why mom's gone like you gotta let
her go then we had to have
um in this in the writing for this
character we had to have seen um how the
rings
or whatever it is since his mother's
death affected him towards either like
an insanity because of his schizophrenia
because he's hearing voices in his head
and then he starts doing irrational
things like making crazy irrational
things to get his way to get his wife
back
murdering yeah no we don't see any of
that he's just a very stoic person
for hearing voices in his head she's a
pretty silly
he's like your your mother is calling me
from outside the gate in this mystical
world which clearly it exists and goes
we need to go find him because they're
holding her captive this podcast is
sponsored by better help is there
something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals my friends that has
been me my whole life until i started
therapy and i got my counseling that i
needed and i'll tell you this right now
your boy is happier than ever now when i
first started out doing this i had
certain thoughts about therapy and
counseling and uh wasn't too favorable i
thought it made me weak but that's just
the stuff that i grew up with and when i
kind of let go of those things and
decide to use better help my life has
been pretty freaking good better help is
committed to facilitate great
therapeutic matches so they can make it
easy and free to change therapists if
needed it's actually more affordable
than traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available for you
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today visit their website
and read their testimonials my friends
you can see how dope it is for yourself
visit betterhelp.com genius that's
better h-e-l-p and join over two million
people who have taken charge over their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help that
they are recruiting additional
therapists in all 50 states special
offer for genius brain listeners get 10
off your first month at
betterhelp.com
genius sounds pretty logical to me yeah
it sounds like what a superhero would do
exactly
like we have to save your mother she's
actually not dead
and once again because it's in the mcu
universe where
it's in the mcu where magic exists this
is clearly a possibility but instead
this [ __ ] who's supposed to be the
hero in this film is just a [ __ ] dick
and we don't know why there's yeah
there's no development for that side
like okay so we maybe we got enough um
empathy but we didn't get the clear
understanding of his and antagonism also
too when he put the dagger in his son's
hand it he didn't say you do this or
you're not my son yeah like right there
was there there was hardly any real
expectations
you know out of each character for
another therefore there was no conflict
it was just
to us as an audience
their their relationship is [ __ ] up
because of miscommunication
you guys need to work on your
communications yes
it's like his son didn't communicate to
his dad that he didn't want to do it and
then he's like i'm mad yeah i'm gonna
run away you didn't seem to tell your
dad any of this in fact it seemed like
you really wanted to do this yeah
yeah i mean like we didn't get
why like we were just supposed to know
that wen wu was the bad guy just because
he's the bad guy and he really wasn't
yeah like if like what is he doing that
other superheroes don't do you know yeah
they they go out and get revenge they go
out and do things for love but when
they're deceived they get the benefit of
the doubt right like when hawkeye was
[ __ ] mind controlled in the first
avengers he's you know like something
that came out of it instead
he died from that kuthu thing his soul
got sucked out yeah
you know just because that's what
happened
there was no oh my god i was being uh
deceived this was a voice and all this
regret
there was no like
uh conflict in the beginning where like
you have to obey me you have to take
over this organization you got to do
what i say
you know it was he just acted that way
towards other ancillary characters
not exactly towards shang qi yeah you
know so therefore we we don't really
get too much of why he's such an
antagonist yeah we don't understand the
motivation behind why he's doing these
things here's the other thing that made
sanchi look super bad too his [ __ ]
father dies he just stares back and just
flies away
that's it
your [ __ ] dad just died bro you had
to save the village
there was no like
you know mourning process for his father
died yeah and by the way
when we go back to this thing the reason
why i really didn't like shanghi's
character it was like he was such a dick
to his dad when he already knew the
motivation which i mentioned before but
he looked at his dad he goes what makes
you think our mom would even want to
talk to you yeah it's like bro
how [ __ ] dare you yeah how [ __ ]
dare you they they had sex you didn't
have sex with your mom
i'm [ __ ] wrong
you're a valid point like seriously
what gives you the cry he's known your
mother way longer than you've known her
gave up
the beauty of their relationship right
it was it was kind of um portrayed in
the choreography he's the brutish guy
straight even his stance fist super
[ __ ] strong she's like the wind and
the water she flows really well yeah he
gave up this he gave up his life and she
also gave up hers to make sure that they
had this they were harmony they were yin
and yang that's this is a beautiful
[ __ ] relationship and this kid
shang chi is just entitled to everything
he's entitled to call his father a piece
of [ __ ] even though what what did he do
to him yeah besides but he trained you
really really [ __ ] hard
which was a goal that you wanted because
you wanted to seek revenge as well
so he killed a man in front of him but
then you took all the training yeah
that's what i'm saying they didn't show
us his resentment they didn't show us
how he
um got out of that lie and therefore
that's why he was in hiding in the first
place the only person whose resentment
might have made sense was his sisters
because she was pushed aside maybe and
then she kind of felt like oh well i had
to learn everything on myself to prove
to my dad that i'm also worthy and i
also have to prove it to my brother
that somewhat made sense to me but you
still assumed that motive we didn't see
any of that motive right that's why at
the end
you know the post credits
uh she takes over the ten rings
organization
why
why
right if we had seen something like um
when will obsessed with training chiang
chi
so he um
he
abandons and neglects or is he named
zhao ling
i think that's her name yeah but uh his
chiang chi sister
and she watched there's one scene where
she watches in the background hen
training and she's picking it up herself
and then she also expositions that
to aquafina you know um
so we we don't see her actually growing
like in resentment for her father
because of her neglect
you know we just kind of assume it
you know and we we would have understood
that like if we saw any intention
for wenmu to give the ten rings to
shanghi that he trained him so that he
could fulfill because he was you know
what my wife's dead i'm ready to give up
give up eternal life right
but then part of
you know the story turn would be that
chiang chi resents the fact that he had
to murder someone and then also because
of the deceptive voices in his head he
decides to keep the rings on longer you
know
and
that's what i mean like we we
saw we should have saw his sister get
jealous
and resentful towards shanghi as well
because she was never going to inherit
the 10 rings but what she could do is to
take over the 10 rings organization yeah
you know and so therefore that's why she
set up the fight club underground so to
you know that she would have a place to
come up you know into that we didn't see
any of that
i just literally thought of a better
story scenario in my head just now
and all that stuff makes perfect sense
too and also too um why is it that his
sister is so quick to forgive shanghi
when he [ __ ] abandoned her yeah why
is she why is he so much better than her
father yeah
i don't understand why is she so all
buddy buddy cool with them now i don't
understand that [ __ ] because they know
kung fu
there's just so many things that just
didn't make [ __ ] sense in this film
like you're mentioning a lot of the the
two sides of the same coin between wen
wound his wife and we could have seen it
between shanghai and his sister too yeah
being like a killmonger t'challa
situation we don't see that we don't see
any motivation we don't see any reason
why
she's going to take up this organization
we get she has
resentment for her father but i don't
know why we don't see any of it you know
she just says yeah he was obsessed also
too let's just talk about this part
right and we're going to go back to um
uh
aquafina's character what's her name
again katie katie
so this girl doesn't know anything jack
[ __ ] about arrows she just learned it in
a day like three or four hours i say
three hours but it was like a day right
yeah comes in
shoots this [ __ ] arrow a single arrow
[ __ ] up this mystical dragon creature's
throat one arrow yeah
so
knowing that a single arrow can [ __ ] up
this crazy beast right which by the way
these arrows are covered in the dragon
scales yeah
the dragon is fighting it
exactly
hey just rub up against it bro
[Laughter]
just
sneeze off he's like no my scales are
more powerful when i'm dead yeah i gotta
shed you know i need some more psoriasis
going on i need a sunburn
i literally was like my dandruff kills
it
[Laughter]
seriously like i mean it was cool like
with the dragon and writing it was kind
of dragon ball z ish they have it like
that's what i'm saying like
they mock this entire third act
when they're back at the bar
because they're like yeah and then i
learned you know bone arrow in a day and
i killed the thing like they just mock
it so we how are we supposed to care if
you don't care
one single arrow hits it in the throat
it's bleeding like a [ __ ] yeah
right
and that's pretty much i can't suck
souls anymore
how come they just all didn't shoot like
a thousand arrows at it i'm pretty sure
if that one single ear that tapped its
throat you would have killed it pretty
easy i mean and you also get a gang
you know we see that they have guns you
know yeah they show up to the magical
universe without the guns
[ __ ] ridiculous yeah
i mean
there's a lot of backwards things that
happen like in between all the lines
though yeah there's good [ __ ]
for sure but
doesn't make it a good movie it doesn't
make it a good movie and here's the
thing too this is the conversation that
i was getting really kind of upset at
right especially when people who i was
talking to about this right they go well
and this always happens with asian
american films which is starting to
really piss me off because we do have a
lot of great actors we do have a lot of
great directors and filmmakers and so
people keep doing this thing where they
see this film and they go
they do this for cg animated films they
do this for all the stuff they go well
what
who's the audience for right it did what
it did for the people who wanted to see
it i was like no no no no
no it's it's jim bob in iowa yeah you
know he has to get in the seats too yeah
it's like no no no you keep making
[ __ ] excuses this film was not made
for children
this film was just made to be a marvel
film yeah general audience got to get
everybody the entire quadrant exactly it
wasn't made for a children's audience
right they're like oh what did you
expect out of marvel films i don't know
[ __ ] the first iron man winter
soldier logan civil war civil war
infinity war infinity war black panther
what are you that's what i keep saying
black panther got nominated for best
picture do people like forget that like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about here
dude so when people keep making excuses
for this stuff right it's like
are you simply okay saying that this is
a great film just because there was a
bunch of asian americans in it right
yeah or just because the fight scenes
were great yeah i'm talking about this
as a film as a whole and once again i'm
saying this as somebody who really
really wanted to like this film we only
feel this way because we wanted it to be
good exactly
and you know what
hater love it we did set the bar with
black panther for
films like this
you know and he had we had the chance
you know to get a a better story some
character [ __ ] growth some culture
no like what was the culture in a
[ __ ] bombed-out gangster base you
know no it was entitled narnia in a
made-up land you know but then we had no
chance to actually care about talo at
all we don't care about as much as we
did asgard even after it blew up we
don't care about it like we do about
wakanda
you know it's just like also too like
the asian jokes too they didn't really
do any service for anybody like that
karaoke joke at the end was so bad dude
or
and they start karaoke right
like that
exactly
and it goes back to that asian was
screaming because her homework got
destroyed in her laptop right i look at
that it's like you like if it if it was
like a black exploitation film you might
as well just had to do with a bucket of
fried chicken and somebody threw it on
the floor yeah like no
exactly come on man do better like do
way better than that what the [ __ ] are
you thinking dude just just
like what do you want here like you said
you wanted this film to uplift asian
americans but you have these very low
hanging fruit [ __ ] asian jokes in it
yeah didn't make sense to me and they
were like unpromising characters with
dead end jobs
and at the end of the film if they're
back in america they're doing the same
thing they were doing dude that's why i
say it's narnia because
they all the magic happens somewhere
else and they go back to their regular
lives and then they try to claim that
they've grown yeah have they
have they
no zero growth and like the majority of
the characters they just didn't emote
like once again like i just like i said
man c was a [ __ ] [ __ ] nice guy
right met him a couple of times we
worked on a wong fu thing together or
whatever
he [ __ ] got no emotion in his
face
it's just the same face it's just the
same [ __ ] face i get it i guess like
look but the whole people saying he's
ugly thing
you know i mean he has a big ass [ __ ]
head that's yeah sure i don't know about
him
he's like the jeremy renner of us he's a
daniel craig yeah
a little potato face but then a handsome
you know yeah he has charm to him yeah
um it's just that you know i think this
had the whole bree larson captain marvel
thing
where
during the press tour
you know we kind of see the character
through you but when we see the real you
and you're obnoxious
you know um and you're arrogant
and then on the screen we're supposed to
buy that you're a superhero it's it's
harder to
want to see or to accept it's harder to
digest
um
the whole time it was just this is what
it is you're in for the right i would
have called it like harold and kumar
meets dragon ball z
you know because think about it if if if
katie and chang ji were
high the whole time it wouldn't have
changed the story do you know what
even think about it like this you know
what this movie is though right what it
the what it's an exact reiteration of a
film that already came out years ago
korean pop star
ninja assassin ninja assassin
[Music]
i gotta see i i saw like the first few
scenes i have never seen so ninja
assassin is p
right
ninja organization
he is the son of a father who is in the
shadow realm of this world aka 10 rings
yeah he disappears fakes his death to
disappear because he was supposed to
either murder somebody or something like
that and he disappears and then his dad
tries to assassinate him or find him
right but the motivation that made sense
because dad's trying to [ __ ] kill him
yeah so he's trying to take this whole
organization down yeah it's literally
[ __ ] ninja assassin
if ninja assassin meets [ __ ] mulan
put right together right is that [ __ ]
mooshu is a giant right
i gotta hand it to them though uh there
was not much chinese propaganda this
time yeah
not a lot of ccp prob
you know this was the potential of what
mulan could have been yeah right like it
really mulan could have been this with
the right choreography and the right
motivation yeah and it just did i think
mulan was also pg-13 as well i believe
so yeah right i don't think it was rated
yet most marvel dc's are pg-13 yeah they
want a blockbuster they're going to take
you to pg-13 because they got to hit all
the quadrants yeah and like how
heartless he was towards his dad and
everything right but at the end he
decides to throw you know float his
spirit in the river it's like why you
treated him like [ __ ] throughout the
whole thing you killed him bro
no i mean he didn't do it the
thing took his life but yeah and i'll
let case just like say that that final
fight scene didn't mean anything it was
supposed to be the most important fight
there was
dope like dragon ball kind of effects
going on when they were when they split
the rings
but it goes through the same tropes of
why we didn't like raya yeah
yeah
yeah the dragon looked better
oh for sure yeah
it went through those same problems that
riot went through you know and also too
because like
because i didn't like the acting i
didn't like the cinematography when it
came to just the dialogue which i don't
know why the director [ __ ] slept on
this one part which is so important
right like composing shots when people
are talking is just as [ __ ] important
as these [ __ ] fight scenes man yeah
if anything is more important because
this is this is the storytelling part
this is where you get to see the
characters come to life this is where
you can see them speak this is where you
get to see the relationship that they
have with the other characters and it
was so plain it was shot so poorly yeah
why why i don't understand that
well from what i understand um
they the way the budget's allocated like
all the action scenes all the fight
scenes all of that's already pre-made
you know the director comes in so with
the mcu like ken feige's um i guess big
money-making part was that he doesn't
get auteur filmmakers
he gets like a lot of tv show directors
because in tv world the producers and
the writers are the most important
people and the directors are there to
make sure everything gets shot the way
it's supposed to be shot yeah and that's
come specifically writers are gone yeah
yeah so uh what kevin feige has been
doing apparently is hiding hiring more
tv
to be more obedient towards their their
mcu silo like there's there's a cannon
there's a this there's this you gotta
have this this and that
and don't waste your time with the
action and this and then we'll we'll
hire a specific team and they will cover
all those parts two different directors
yeah it's basically there's two
different parts that of of well that
explains why it seems so disjointed it
seemed like i was watching two films in
one yeah i mean like there are directors
who quit some i think some director quit
miss uh captain marvel because
when she she had ideas about action
scenes and they're like no we actually
have
taken care of and there's all these
pre-visuals right yeah
look i think that does well honestly as
a formula as a blockbuster as billion
dollar industry and you know it looks
great
and the director isn't known for doing
action
yeah
i think that's that's fine right but if
you are taking care of everything in
between those fight scenes
you're not doing
the job yeah it's just such a disservice
it looks it looked like it was two
separate films
it just it looks so stupid like it's one
of those movies you have to sit and wait
till the fight scene happens yeah that's
what it felt like and that's why there
was moments where it was very [ __ ]
boring because i had to sit through that
terrible [ __ ] dialogue and you know
these actors who probably would have
done a better job of the writing was
better so you know i'm not knocking
their skill level right it's just more
like
i mean it was pretty [ __ ] bad like
yeah
like the the shang chi moment going back
to the part where he's crying it was
the most laughable [ __ ] emotional
scene i've ever seen in my life yeah
it's like acting 101 when you're sad put
your hand to your face when you're sad
look away
what the [ __ ] man and then you have this
and that was probably the only moment
that um the katy character was a little
more toned down yeah where she felt a
little more real yeah and
and by the way if people say like well
she has to be loud that's why she's
funny guess who was really [ __ ] funny
in that film bennett did long yeah he
wasn't live straight he played it
straight and he was [ __ ] hilarious
and then people were like well you know
he's a he's a he's a classically trained
theatrical actor so okay great so you
know that they suck then
so you're making an excuse for them yeah
right and once again i'm not knocking
them as people or anything else like
that but when you know that you're
it has to be the writing at this point
because you have people like but then
again look at tony lung
he also had the same writers yeah but he
killed every single one of his lines he
he did he made lemonade out of the
lemons he was given yeah you know um it
was just we we feel this way
because of the bar that was set
you know and look i wasn't looking for
the black panther type of hype you know
where like well the bar was set in the
first 15 minutes of the film yeah it was
dope yeah
it just didn't it didn't call back any
of the conflicts
uh
uh it resolved things that we didn't
know that was a problem in the first
place like yeah man and then the
characters are the same people at the
end i mean like
movies that do that have need a specific
reason why they're the same person like
indiana jones he's the same character
through
from the beginning to the end because
it's a serialization you know yeah and
they go oh well you know look at the
other mcu films like how the dialogue
how's the dialogue in that i'm like bro
it's pretty good very good
the jokes are pretty [ __ ] good man
when you see uh steve rogers talk about
his love for the country bro that [ __ ]
hits me yeah his speeches are like they
go hard yeah but like i mean
specifically too let's go back to phase
one and look at natalie portman's
character you know she was the uh
eyeballs of the audience
but then the way it served the story was
that she was an astrophysicist yeah you
know she was a scientist and she was
trying to explain everything that goes
down because um up to this point in the
mcu it would be really weird to have a
space alien that's a
you know a
nord god yeah you know like a nordic god
like thor
you know
why did we need natalie portman so that
we could see it through her eyes as a
scientist to make sense of all this and
suspend our disbelief because it's
happening she's not stopping and like
looking at the camera like well i guess
this is happening
like no she's processing it it's
unbelievable but then through the movie
through her shoes we are suspending our
disbelief and thor even explains it like
what you call science and to us you
think it's magic they're one and the
same yeah you know we believe in asgard
because it's not a magical realm in the
classic sense we think
it is advanced technology the same with
wakanda it's not magic it's not all
magic it's like advanced technology
what's the mythicism yeah we didn't get
any of that in chiang chi it was just
here you go take it or leave it welcome
to disneyland you know and they kind of
always already dropped the gem about you
know the the marvel universe and
everything that has happened before this
is global [ __ ] people know what's going
on in the world with with magic
superpower heroes spider-man all this
other stuff yeah so even now too if i
really think about it when these people
in the bar they're like oh oh oh it's
like bro you the world almost ended you
saw it yeah how you guys disappeared
you you you saw what's up yeah you know
when you see this it's not like i can't
believe it it should be like oh [ __ ]
something's about to happen you know so
it just
just just didn't make sense man it
it was part of the mcu by canon just
because they say so but then
literally it was shoehorned in sort of
really like
just thinking about this being a
standalone film like just wouldn't stand
up on its own it's got a disney marvel
tag on it yeah you know it's got other
mcu characters and you know what makes
this cameo this is the problem that a
lot of marvel films kind of go through
with people who are
fair weather or they don't even like
marvel that much right it can't stand on
its own because people don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on yeah it's hard to
follow like it's it's really hard to
follow sometimes and by the way huge
marvel fan you know like i said we just
went through a litany of all the marvel
films that we [ __ ] love right yeah so
i and i can understand too why people
just get confused sometimes the only one
film that probably people saw that i
know that they really enjoyed that they
didn't really care to see anything else
was logan yeah
really yeah because logan was like there
was all this crazy stuff that was
happening
but at the same time i think like
that's what i'm talking about when
people talk about dialogue right it's
like they don't need great logan yeah
was amazing [ __ ] yeah like one of my
not just marvel films one of my favorite
films of all time oh yeah it's great in
general it's such a good
that could have been nominee for best
picture too i kind of feel like i got
snubbed it did get snubbed it was so
[ __ ] good yeah like we can get past
the fact that this [ __ ] has like
claws coming out of his hands same with
his clone and um and a telekinetic old
man and all this [ __ ] it's like we get
past the fact with mutants and
superpowers this is a [ __ ] engaging
story yeah and when you look and
you know just to use that as an example
because we are talking about the marvel
universe we look at somebody like logan
right he's rough around the edges he's
kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] the way that
he talks to people the way that he
treats people right yeah you know there
didn't have to be a whole exposition
about his past and where he grew up in
japan doesn't even know how old he is
the whole adamantium thing or whatever
you didn't need to know any of that you
could see him struggling to be a good
person with his relationship with
professor xavier yeah right yeah he's
taking care of him he's trying to do all
these good things or whatever and he's
trying to let go of this old past and
he's trying to just survive at this
point so you already feel this thing for
him you kind of pity him already yeah
you know and you see him just kind of
traipsing along going through
a bunch of these trials and tribulations
when he's just trying to stay the [ __ ]
away and this little girl comes in right
yeah [ __ ] with him [ __ ] with his
emotions and [ __ ] with the sense of who
he is and you get to see him start to
become more humanized yes right
you didn't need exposition to know any
of that [ __ ] and in fact you didn't need
to know any of the marvel backstory yeah
but just in the film alone in terms of
the writing the dialogue and the
storytelling we get a grasp of this and
it was just a snippet yeah of his life
so maybe shanxi didn't have to have the
whole story told in one episode right
yeah but they probably did it because
they needed to carry on for another film
yeah i mean we know there's going to be
a sequel
we know you know this is a huge thing
for both uh aquafina and simalu they're
going to be in a bunch of other mcu
properties you know
um this is good you know for asian
americans in general to have a place
it's just uh objective
i don't know i don't know if i want to
say objectively either in our opinions
like we had high hopes we wished it was
better we just feel this way because
it's not
yeah
like i said and just to bring it back
there's a [ __ ] ton of marvel movies i
like yeah and
this one was a fat miss for me yeah it
wasn't missed once again great great
choreography
[Laughter]
we're trying we're trying we're trying
to sandwich this with good stuff at the
end
great great choreography and i will
never ever say representation is a
reason why a film is good you just you
can't force people to
you know
start changing you know their attitudes
specifically for this one mediocre movie
um just because
you know like it's for the culture is it
you know yeah what is what does that
even mean anymore right it's like this
is for the culture cool we'll make it
for the culture and also make it make
sense how about that yeah it doesn't
even matter how loud we are about how
great this movie is
it's if like we said if jim bob and iowa
liked it you know maybe he did maybe he
did uh i just think for me personally
it's probably in the lower
five mcu films yes yeah big facts dude
yeah i mean it wasn't hulk bad original
hulk bad yeah definitely not like that
you know what i'm saying yeah but this
was not one of my favorites dude there
are so much better ones to say that this
is like one of the best marvel films
ever you are
out here you're [ __ ] mine dude yeah
that's crazy talk dude yeah i think we
are afforded to actually say hey look
without the whole asian thing and any of
that [ __ ] really this is not that great
i think we at least have the privilege
to say this yeah you know i think we
could say that without walking around
eggshells just like
[Music]
it's like what did you think of the film
it's like i thought the representation
was i didn't ask you about the [ __ ]
representation yeah i'm saying what
about that that's the weird thing about
wool culture these days it's like people
care more about more about what a movie
means than the fact that if it's a good
film at all yeah and it's and by the way
when you talk about what a movie means
now nowadays like why is it that a a
grading system for a film now is what it
personally meant to you or how it
affects the culture yeah like or the the
pop culture sphere like the dent it
makes and it's like like if we try to
have a conversation and we talk about
these specific points and they just go
well i was represented that's not that's
not a discussion about the parts that we
had either gripes with or the stuff that
we really liked i i mean
i didn't see myself anywhere in this
movie
you know if i didn't see myself in a
shang chi kind of thing if i did like
the way he handled is look i i grew up
with bad a bad father let's say you know
with uh his father
rich as hell yeah gave him everything
but i
my my dad was pretty antagonistic you
know he was a quote-unquote bad guy you
know
to society in certain forms
um and there were a lot of ways that i
have to deal with that
i mean if this guy is our hero
we got to see him go through the journey
of what it means to be
you know the you know a hero or the path
he chooses instead of the path his
father wants for him like darth vader
and luke skywalker it wasn't like that
at all it was just this teenage angst
that's stayed over since he was 14 when
he's supposed to be like i think he's
supposed to be like 26 in the movie but
yeah he's he's much older than yeah he's
like 32-33 or something i think he had a
class of 17 t-shirt when they went to
the karaoke yeah let's not do that yeah
yeah all right i think more or less
class of osa also too like one note
thing that i think i didn't understand
is was like
how like you know when the ring switched
over and it changed colors when he did
it yeah why
what how like what was it what was the
right well that was the color changed to
when his mom had the rings for a sec
before throwing it back at him and i
guess that's
a thing and he just threw it at him in
that color and then
i think that's what it was it was just
good guy color like yeah i i believe so
i think it's just good kite color you
know and then like they kind of hint at
oh something else it came from
somewhere not of this universe you know
at the post credit scene and by the way
too like for him for the kids too up
until the point where his mother passed
away and his father decided you know the
eternal life thing again in order to
make sure that people stop [ __ ] with
his family which is actually a really
good thing for him to do
like their kid children's life was great
they were up in a [ __ ] mountain they
were chilling with their mom living in
this great palace yeah
that house looks dope yeah
dad was [ __ ] going down the
mountainside getting groceries somehow
which i have no idea how that happened
you know like nobody went to go get it
he took his helicopter yeah
you know seemed like it seemed like he
had a pretty good life so he didn't know
about his dad's conquering days and
stuff yeah like it's that's the problem
we didn't see him
come of age yeah we didn't see him at 14
being like wait all of this was wrong
all of this is a lie
we didn't see any of that we just know
he feels salty yeah and once again kind
of communication skill problems because
it's just like he was just holding it
and not telling his dad yeah and then
expecting his dad to read his mind
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] was that well guys
that wraps up this review of shang qi
i'm so curious as to what everybody else
thought most likely i'm pretty sure
people are going to hate us
would you recommend it
i would recommend this i recommend it
that's why it has 92 percent on to me
yes it's favorable i would give it a 50
on rotten tomatoes
i will give it a 50 which is not bad i
give it a
solid b minus you know well you're a lot
favored yeah yeah i gave it 50 people
everything i have to complain about look
they they put a lot of work into it we
don't we're not the type of people like
you don't have to be like you know there
was hundreds of people who put thousands
of hours of time and says we understand
that our problem is that hundreds of
people put thousands of hours into this
script yeah
and this is what we got from it but once
again like yeah would i recommend it
yeah i 100 recommend it i think you
should watch it just for the fight
scenes alone it's it's pretty [ __ ]
amazing shout out to uh what was it uh
brandon allen yeah
um i don't know
oh a jackie chance duncan who passed
away oh
i think he was a pretty big integral
part into the the choreography of this
film as well right so i gotta look at
that rest in peace man um yeah 100
recommend the film wasn't a big fan of
it but definitely
i don't regret watching it me neither i
saw it twice i don't think i need to see
it anymore yeah i'm not watching it
twice that's not happening but uh yeah
guys you can catch ed at ed parkvp
and uh you could catch genius frames
every thursdays and sundays and name
other films that you want us to watch
and review i love watching films and i
love breaking it down with ed so we will
see you all next time peace peace